me
ん
[音楽]
me
あるところに
桜という男がいました
大わー
砥堀持ちでした
ブーブーピッいっ
釣ったたっつって建てたと言っ
ん
しゃべるときに
言葉が使えたり
喉の奥の方で詰まったりそして時々
思うように喋れないことがありました
こうして
毎日の会話になかなか苦労していたようです
電車乗り場で切符を買うときは
順番に並んでいるそばから
そうそうはしていました市駅にの駅さんの役とあって
大鰐の駅の切符が欲しかったのですが
任意が言えなかったんです
客さんどちらまで
じゃああの
どちらまで
山の駅までれ
本当は
以後いけなのに
その先の山の駅までを買いました
王はその都度落ち込みました
みの駅が言えなかったからって
そうではありません
どもりを隠すために
本当は言いたくない自分の気持ちに嘘をついていたからです
こうして
なかなか会話に苦労していたようです
そんな大毎日
面白がってなろうか心配してなのか
いろんな人が近づいてきました
えっ大佐
おっさん good morning 今日も1日ババクって撮っ10日
東の山の方から by 朝ジョギングでやってくる
頬兄弟
お山ついに聞いてください
二中を流れる水の流れが発見できそうですこうしてダウジング棒を持っていくと
じゃあここに水が流れてまず
[音楽]
お待ちで謎の井戸掘り研究をする浮き博士
ふう香簿食パンガー
焼けたわよツイスト常夏もいかが
fire の売り子さん米
サンバを踊るくねくねねーさん
あるとき街にいるいろんな人たちのしゃべり方を見ていたをはふと
そのしゃべり方を真似してみました
すると
すらすらと言葉が出てきたのです
ペッを
尾根をさんは酔う初めましてオですかなんてプチッと言わてくるヒトラー
お客さんどちらまで
a
みの駅片道大人1枚ください
[音楽]
兵器月今日もネズミが取れた可愛い
方は
モノマネがとっても得意でした
ところが小さな細い
曲の一つ一つまでまでができたものですからいろんな人のいろんな特徴がぐちゃぐちゃ
に混ざって
ちぐはぐになってしまいました
おーわー
困りました
そこで
とスラスラペラペラ
はい気遣いで
ズバット蹴り込んだ
ダダンと具体を出す人になろうと
ペラペラペラペラだー
竜二潮流朝ズバッだドン
留鳥流暢ず板
パターン
ペラペラからからからいう調理部長ズバーン
だだ
繰り返し繰り返し
一瞬不乱に練習しました
すると
あるとき服の袖口あたりからなんだかぶら下がっていることに気がつきました
服の糸がほつれたのか
ゴミがくっついているのかよくわかりません
このまま引っ張ったら服に穴があいてしまうか
と一瞬頭によぎったのですが a めんどくさくなってそのプラ下がっているものを
引き継ぎました
すると
prova 理由もなく床に落ちました
それではまた
すらすら sera sera sera sera ペラペラペラペラ旧町立津幡が
スラスラさらさなくながらぶらぶら
流潮流中ズバッただすら皿皿皿からからクリトリス捜査側に殴られぞれ
あくる日もは来る日もそれはもう自分丸ごと
粘土で形作るみたいにこれでもかこれでもかと
練習しました
それとパターン
体のどこからか
なんとかぶら下がって
気になってというより
いつになく
憎たらしく覚えて
つからいっぱい
つ切りました
それでまた唾するはスラスラベラベラベラベラ
ついには息の吸い方から真央滝の仕方まで気になり始め
呪文のように捉えました
スロスロスロするヅラべらべらべらべらべら龍超級中スパーダちゅらズラズラズラで
どんどん変わりましたしゃべるスピードはスポーツカーのように速く
頭の中で完璧に整理した言葉を順番通りに喋れるように
無駄なことは一つも言わない奴らんと言われるようになり
立ち姿は自身にみなぎり
高級ブティックのスーツを着て
お金持ちの社長さんや
宝石まみれの王様と
往来しましたあっはっは
していつしか一人になると
暗い部屋で
としていました
ああああああ
o さん最近皮付き変わったじゃねーか
ああ
日もしないでー前にしてかけていくよ
家に帰ってもエアの明かりもつけないでどうしたのか知らん
方は
いつも
ピリピリとして
目の下にクマを作って
こうバッタ目つけない
つい周りの人も
声を掛けなくなりました
やがて体
大野が茶房
聞かなくなりました
ある日の夕暮れ度聞い
車を運転していた方はう
いつになく疲れを感じゼーゼーと
息が漏れました
ダッダーンと
mk が押し寄せてきて
雨の前の景色が
遠くになっていくのが見えた次の瞬間危ない
目の前に
黙々と
煙が立ち上っていました
すると
煙はだんだんと黒くなって
クローイ煙がシュート集まったかと思うと
大きな影になって
大野目の前に覆いかぶさってきましたあーあ朦朧としながらその黒い影を見上げると
ていうか
誰
誰だって俺は壁だ
カッコフェと
だったらご
誰のものでもない影で
世の中に持ち主のいない影っていうのもある
あんた
俺と取引しないか
取引
難しく考えることはなんだよ
夫
自分の影を見て皆
色が薄くなってたろう
q かかっていう
ということだよ
慌てるな
あんたなぁ
自分の影を捨てちまったんだよ
ほんとどんもりがあったなぁ喋る時につっかえ取り繰り返したり
それはあんたの中にいたらいろんな自分がやっていたことで本当の中にはこれまで
前のめりでつんのめっているようなやつや
ビリゆったりしてる奴や
おっ顔だけ室はな体してる垂木みたいにキョロキョロしてるようなやつまで
そいつらは
あったがこれまでの人生
出て行ってきた者たちさ
そいつらがあったの中で折り重なって折り重なって
あったこれまでやってきたああああ
ところが
シッターたわ
すらすらと分妻らずに
になって必須になるほどその no
ビリーのやつやちょっと縁があ
邪魔になって切り離してまた
離されたそいつらは行き場がなくなって
ただの影だけになった
一度キー原されたかけは二度と戻らねぇ
ローマモードと後は聞いてしまう
そこで
取引台
俺を
あったの影にしないか
するトッドと堂々なんだよ
お灸ずに済むよその香り
アッターの半分が
俺もある
アブーたんですかって
あっほら good ぬくっ
エアーそうくると思ったらおいそれじゃあ
潮
あんたが消えずに済む方法
教えてやるう n
ん
その代わり
俺は
他の言葉が欲しい
ウッドのしゃべり方は人を自分の世界に巻き込む力がある
そんな風にすらスレットしゃべられたら大抵の人間はコロって行っちまうそうだろ
オレはあの話術が欲しいんだ
俺も言葉を渡したら
となったようまたともに戻るのかへへどうだっけ
あーちゃんと考えてあるさ
ついて聞いてくれ
簡単中にな最後の一つだけ残っている影がある
それがあったとって最後のチャンスだ
ウルブカに一日塗装
もしあんたが
自分の言葉を渡すんだったらその陰とうまくやっていく方法教えてやる
そしてらあったのこと
巣瀬も消えることはねーずん
やってくねよし取引成立だいいか
あんたの中に残ってる最後の影やなぁ
田名部という子供の影だ
田名部は
耳が聞こえない
あったが子供の頃にあった子だ
トラムは目の前で口を大きく開いて喋れば口の形で何を言っているのかが分かった
そうやって聞こえなくても会話することができてあった嬉しかった
そのうれしい気持ちがあった中にずっと住み続けてたんですよ
それこそ
他の影を切り離してしまった時もその音に気づかず
turn turn 中に残ってたってわけしたなう
悪化
たナムと会った時のことを思い出しては何
その陰とを開けていくことができるサ
あんた言葉を失う
友利ですがなくなる
その代わり
まったく別の
音の無い言葉の世界でゼロから生きていくんだよ
心の準備はいいか
今から
3つ数えるうちに
ほらあんたの影をいただいて
言葉をいただいていなくなる
一つ
2つ
その後のことは
誰も知りません
そしてある時
o ニー
一つの言葉が生まれました
[拍手]